[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport heute
die Welt Ernährung als Waffe nach
Russlands aus für das getreideabkommen
hebt Moskau auch Sicherheitsgarantien
für ukrainische Transporte auf
im Heim und bald Arm der Eigenanteil für
Pflegebedürftige ist drastisch gestiegen
experten warnen immer weniger können
sich das noch leisten
und Südeuropa schwitzt und leidet am
Mittelmeer gilt in vielen Städten
Alarmstufe Rot rund um Athen wüten
weiter brennende
hören sie auf Hunger als Waffe zu
benutzen so appellierte Außenministerin
baerbock erneut an den Kreml doch
Russland bleibt dabei kein
getreideabkommen mehr dazu die Warnung
weitere Exporte aus der Ukraine ohne
russische Zustimmung sein riskant was
dieses Abkommen bedeutet zeigt ein Blick
auf die Details 33 Millionen Tonnen
Getreide konnte die Ukraine seit August
exportieren vor allem meist aber auch
Weizen und Ölsaaten größte Abnehmer war
China mit fast 8 Millionen Tonnen es
folgen Spanien und die Türkei deutlich
weniger importierten afrikanische
Staaten wie Kenia Äthiopien oder Jemen
doch für die teils hungernde Bevölkerung
dort sind die Lieferungen essentiell
Volker Duczek
der türkische Frachter TQ Samson ist das
womöglich letzte Schiff das vorerst in
Istanbul kontrolliert wurde
15.000 Tonnen Raps aus der Ukraine jetzt
auf dem Weg in die Niederlande
das aus das getreideabkommens hat
Auswirkungen in der ganzen Welt auch in
Kenia eine Mühle in der Stadt Kika
Nairobi ein Teil der 437.000 Tonnen
Getreide aus der Ukraine landet hier die
starke Inflation hohe Spritpreise und
jetzt noch die Unsicherheit wie hoch der
Getreidepreis steigen wird
wir müssen jetzt sehen wie es in
nächster Zeit weitergeht
rund 75% unseres Weizens kommt über das
Schwarze Meer zu uns
der Transport übers Meer gilt als
alternativlos vor allem was die Kosten
und die Zeit angeht
wenn man sich zum Beispiel vor Augen
hält dass ein Lastwagen maximal 40
Tonnen transportieren kann die
Frachtschiffe aber typischerweise 25.000
bis 30.000 Tonnen ist klar dass es sehr
sehr schwer ist den unterbrochenen
Seeweg über den Landweg zu kompensieren
in einer ersten Reaktion hat ukraines
Präsident selenski angekündigt die
weizenexporte künftig ohne Russland
durchzuführen doch der Kreml warnt heute
unverhohlen solche Alleingänge sein ohne
russische Sicherheitsgarantien ein
großes Risiko eine deutliche Botschaft
ist auch die Welle von russischen
Angriffen auf die schwarzmeerhäfen in
Odessa nicolayef dabei soll auch ein
Treibstofflager getroffen worden sein
vor Ort in Odessa ist unsere
ja offiziell sagt Russland die Angriffe
auf Odessa sei eine Vergeltungsmaßnahme
für die Sprengung an der krimbrücke doch
in Russland wird man auch die
ukrainischen Gedankenspiele vernommen
haben dass man eine Fortsetzung der
weizenexporter oder Getreideexporte ohne
russische Beteiligung ins Auge fasst
gestern betonte selenski
formaljuristisch sei das
getreideabkommen ja ein Abkommen
zwischen der Ukraine der Türkei und der
UN und ein anderes Abkommen zwischen
Russland der Türkei und der UN und nur
das sei aufgelöst worden heute legte er
nach und sagte Räder er sein Gespräch
mit internationalen Rädern um Sie zu
überzeugen dass sie weiter exportieren
die Luftangriffe genau auf den Hafen von
Odessa zeigen natürlich allen unter
welchen Risiko eine Fortsetzung
stattfinden würde
danke schön für diese Information live
aus Art Dessert danke daran
nach Deutschland für Menschen die in
Pflegeheimen wohnen wird das Leben immer
teurer zuletzt so drastisch dass viele
die Kosten kaum noch stemmen können
warnt der Verband der Ersatzkassen die
Versicherung übernimmt nur die reinen
Pflegekosten und auch die nicht immer
ganz den Rest etwa Unterbringung und
essen muss jeder selbst bezahlen im
Schnitt waren das für neubewohner
zuletzt gut
2.500 Euro pro Monat das sind fast 350
Euro mehr als vor einem Jahr der Anstieg
geht vor allem auf höhere Personalkosten
zurück
ein Platz im Heim für viele bald
unbezahlbar die Zahlungen die
pflegebedürftige aus eigener Tasche
beisteuern müssen sind in diesem Jahr
nochmals deutlich angestiegen so eine
Auswertung des Verbands der Ersatzkassen
wenn das nicht begrenzt wird dann heißt
das für die Zukunft dass die Belastung
immer weiter steigt für die einzelnen
und die Zuschüsse die der ähm die
Pflegeversicherung ab nächsten Jahr
zahlt die höheren Zuschüsse werden auf
Dauer das nicht auffangen können
verantwortlich für den drastisch
steigenden Eigenanteil vor allem höhere
Löhne seit letztem Herbst muss
Pflegepersonal nach Tarif bezahlt werden
die Folge immer öfter überfordern die
Kosten Pflegebedürftige und ihre Familie
Pflege als Armutsrisiko
wir erkennen ja heute schon dass immer
mehr
Pflegebedürftige in die Sozialhilfe
Abrutschen waren das Frühjahr ca 30
Prozent hören wir heute schon Zahlen von
um die 40 Prozent um die Tendenz ist
steigen mit der Pflegereform werden die
Zuschüsse zum Eigenanteil ab nächstem
Jahr leicht steigen wohl keine
nachhaltige Entlastung denn die Kosten
werden schneller klettern eine
Vollversicherung könnte helfen oder neue
Finanzierungsmodelle die Länder sollten
ihre Investitionskosten in den
Pflegeeinrichtungen übernehmen das tun
sie bisher nicht das müssen die
Pflegebedürftigen aus eigener Tasche
zahlen damit könnten sie über 400 €
entlastet werden im Monat eine große
Reform der Pflege Finanzierung scheint
nötig denn die Zahl der Menschen die
unter der Kostenexplosion leidet nimmt
zu
der Ablauf der Doppelwahl in Berlin im
September 2021 war ein ziemliches
Desaster ein Mix aus Stadtmarathon
Corona Regeln und eklatanten Mängeln bei
der Vorbereitung führte zu krassen
Pannen die Wahl zum Berliner
Abgeordnetenhaus musste daraufhin
wiederholt werden was die Pannen für die
Bundestagswahl bedeuten dass prüft ab
heute das Bundesverfassungsgericht Jan
Henrich hat mehr
lange Wartezeiten fehlende Stimmzettel
und bis weit nach 18 Uhr geöffnete
Wahllokale bei der Stimmabgabe in Berlin
im September 2021 kam es zu zahlreichen
Problemen nun sollen auch Teile der
Bundestagswahl wiederholt werden doch in
welchem Umfang darüber wird gestritten
der Bundestag hat eine Wiederholungswahl
in 431 von rund 2300 einzelnen
Wahllokalen im gesamten Stadtgebiet
beschlossen zu wenig findet die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion und Zugfahrt
Bundesverfassungsgericht
angesichts des systemischen Versagens
dass wir dort
feststellen können flächendeckend
feststellen können in zumindest der
Hälfte der Wahlkreise ist es nur
angemessen dann auch in diesem größeren
Umfang neu zu wählen Vertreter der
ampelparteien halten dagegen wir sind
der Meinung es geht wegen des
Demokratieprinzips und seiner besonderen
Bedeutung nicht dass wir vorschnell
komplette wiederholungswahlen
durchführen die Bürger die ihre Stimme
abgeben konnten und das waren zwei
Drittel die müssen schon die Sicherheit
haben dass ihre Stimme zählt und dass
diese Stimme nicht vorschnell im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes in der Tonne
landet für die Richterinnen und Richter
ist vor allem eine Frage wichtig haben
sich die Wahl Pannen tatsächlich auf die
Sitzverteilung im Bundestag ausgewirkt
denn nur dann und in dem Umfang kann
eine Wahl für ungültig erklärt werden
eine Entscheidung wird frühestens in
einigen Wochen erwartet dass eine
teilwiederholung an den
Mehrheitsverhältnissen im Bundestag
insgesamt etwas ändert ist allerdings
höchst unwahrscheinlich
der CDU-Politiker Thorsten freiwilders
individuelle Grundrecht auf Asyl
abschaffen stattdessen solle ist
Kontingente für Verfolgte Menschen geben
die in der EU verteilt werden können der
Vorstoß des
fraktionsgeschäftsführers fand in den
anderen Parteien kaum Zustimmung die
Regierungsparteien lehnten ihn als
realitätsfern ab
illegale Migration könne man so nicht
stoppen
Flüchtlinge auf dem Weg nach Europa wo
man seit Jahren über ihre Verteilung
streitet
Flüchtlingsunterkünfte in Deutschland
auch hier sorgen fragen wie
Unterbringung und Finanzierung für
dauercent um die Zahlen zu drücken kommt
eine Förderung aus der CDU ein
Systemwechsel beim Asylrecht eine
sogenannte Institutsgarantie
das bedeutet im Klartext dass man keine
individuellen Rechtsansprüche mehr hat
sondern dass Europa sich entscheidet
eine bestimmte Zahl von vulnerablen
Menschen in Europa aufzunehmen man
könnte von 300.000 von 400.000 Menschen
ausgehen die
flüchtlingshilfeorganisation PRO ASYL
reagiert entsetzt auf den Vorschlag er
ist außerhalb des Grundgesetzes da gibt
es eine Menschenwürde gehabt er ist
außerhalb des europarest im Ergebnis ist
der freivorschlag genauso
radikal wie die Vorschläge der AFD
Flucht und Migration das Kernthema der
AFD die in Teilen rechtsextreme
parteiverzeichnet derzeit einen
Höhenflug in den Umfragen die SPD
vermutet dies als Grund hinter dem
cdu-vorstoß ich glaube dass Herr Frey
mit dieser Forderung versucht am ganz
ganz rechten äußeren Rand zu fischen ich
rate dringend dazu gerade der CDU und
Herrn frei dringend dazu zur Besinnung
zu kommen und sich nicht bei der AFD
anzuwanzen die Reaktion der Grünen
ebenso knapp wie deutlich offensichtlich
sind wir schon im Sommerloch
wenig Begeisterung viel Kritik also für
den Vorstoß der CDU
im Iran hat das Regime den Druck auf
Andersdenkende massiv verschärft
Bürgerrechtsaktivisten Anwälte und
Journalisten würden festgenommen oder
bedroht und auch die berüchtigte
Sittenpolizei ist wieder auf den Straßen
aktiv und macht Jagd auf Frauen die sich
nicht an die Kleiderordnung halten so
soll ein Wiederaufleben der Proteste vom
vergangenen Jahr verhindert werden Anna
Feist berichtet
ich komme nicht mit lass meine Hände los
schreibt diese Frau ohne Kopftuch als
diese sittenwächterin mit Burka sie zu
einem weißen van ziehen will es ist
Freitag der 14 Juli in der Altstadt von
Teheran das Video geht viral in den
sozialen Medien folgt prompt ein
Aufschrei ihr verdient Geld weil ihr
unschuldige Frauen in den bandschleppt
schande über euch dieses Video wird für
ihn Folgen haben dazu später mehr sie
sind zurück auf den Straßen Irans die
weißen Vans mit den Wächtern über die
Kleiderordnung ganz weg waren sie nie
doch nun soll ihr Einsatz gestärkt
werden verkündet Sonntag die iranische
Polizei ab heute werden überall im Land
Polizei Patrouillen gegründet
trotz dieser Ankündigung trauen sich
Tage später hier in diesem gut
situierten Viertel in Nord Teheran viele
Frauen ohnehin Job auf die Straße haben
Sie keine Angst
wir sind so viele und wir haben keine
Angst mehr
diese Kontrollen werden nichts bringen
das könnte sogar der Auslöser sein für
eine Revolution wie die vom letzten Jahr
ein verzweifelter versucht die Kontrolle
zurück zu gewinnen vor dem ersten
Jahrestag der Proteste denkt dieser
Kritiker das Regime weiß nicht weiter
sie stehen unter dem Druck ihrer eigenen
Kräfte und tun einfach irgendetwas
noch zeigt sich das Regime zynisch eine
Frau jüngst verurteilt zur
zwangs-therapie eine andere soll einen
Monat lang Leichen waschen aufgeben
wollen viele trotzdem nicht so lässt
sich der Mann der offen das Regime
kritisierte nicht einfach festnehmen mit
heruntergelassener Hose hängt er am
Fensterbrett als die Polizei seine
Wohnung stürmt auch dieses Bild
verbreitet sich im Internet
ob in der Medizin im Auto oder im
Militär immer mehr Bereiche bedienen
sich künstlicher Intelligenz lassen sich
Texte schreiben oder Daten analysieren
diese Technologie wächst rasant genau
wie die Sorge davor führende ki-experten
warnten in einem offenen Brief vor einem
möglichen Ende der Menschheit jetzt hat
sich die UNO zum ersten Mal mit dem
Thema beschäftigt
was wenn Maschinen schlauer werden als
wir Menschen wie sicher ist die Welt
dann noch im UN-Sicherheitsrat geht es
um die Gefahren künstlicher Intelligenz
und um ihren Nutzen
künstliche Intelligenz wird alles im
menschlichen Leben verändern
fundamentale Entdeckung in der Medizin
könnten vor der Tür stehen aber KI kann
globale strategische Stabilität
verbessern oder stören
auf politische Destabilisierung Zielen
künstlich erzeugte Videos wieder
Zusammenbruch des französischen
Präsidenten
oder auch Putin der hier angeblich auf
Englisch der US-Bevölkerung droht
wahr oder Fake gefährliche Konfusion ist
meistens global Experten halten deshalb
eine Art Aufsichtsbehörde etwa nach dem
Vorbild der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde für nötig
wir müssen uns künstliche Intelligenz
globaler nähern und nicht nur beherrscht
durch die Sicherheitsratsmitglieder oder
die Gesine wir müssen alle Länder
weltweit einschließen
Manipulationen sind überall denkbar bei
sensiblen Infrastrukturen oder bei der
Kriegsführung KI könnte den
Rüstungswettlauf befeuern auch im
zivilenbereich gibt es eine Gefahr eines
wettlaufes der dazu führen könnte dass
noch nicht ganz ausgereifte ki-systeme
in die Welt gebracht werden und auch das
kann die stabilisierend sein London lädt
im Herbst zu einer globalen ki-konferenz
ein den tech-konzern allein wollen sie
die Verantwortung nicht überlassen
mit den Möglichkeiten und Gefahren von
künstlicher Intelligenz gerade auch im
militärischen Einsatz beschäftigt sich
ZDF heute live um 19:30 Uhr in unserer
App und auf den Social Media Kanälen
seine Sätze seien so schön dass man sie
sich auf den Arm tätowieren möchte das
sagt ein Kritiker über Lutz Sailer den
neuen Georg Büchner-Preisträger für das
was er schreibe sagt der 60-Jährige
Seiler Spiele wahrscheinlich seine
Herkunft eine ziemlich große Rolle seine
Herkunft aus einer vom Uranbergbau
verwüsteten thüringischen Landschaft
neben Gedichten schreibt Seiler
preisgekrönte Romane wie cruso oder
Stern 111
wer Urlaub gebucht hat dürfte es längst
gemerkt haben Reisen ist im ersten
Halbjahr deutlich teurer geworden heißt
es vom Statistischen Bundesamt im
Vergleich zum letzten Jahr musste man
beispielsweise für Pauschalreisen tiefer
in die Tasche greifen ein Plus von 10,2%
und internationale Flüge sind sogar um
24,9% teurer geworden
Spanien Italien oder Griechenland im
Mittelmeer Raum ist es brütend heiß
Italiens Wetterdienst waren vor einer
der intensivsten Hitzewelle aller Zeiten
im Landkind in mehr als 20 Städten die
Alarmstufe Rot inzwischen wurden teils
über 40 Grad gemessen ähnlich ist es in
Griechenland landesweit sind Waldbrände
ausgebrochen nahe Athen sind mehrere
Feuer außer Kontrolle Andreas Postel
berichtet
mit der Hitze kommen die Feuer in der
Nähe von Athen kämpfen Rettungskräfte
gegen die ersten Waldbrände dieser
Saison in kovaras und einigen anderen
Ferienorten fressen sich die Flammen
Rasen schnell an die Häuser heran
Dimitris saviropolus kann nur noch
zusehen
einige versuchen noch das Haus zu
schützen aber das ist hoffnungslos der
Wind ist sehr sehr stark da kann man
nichts mehr machen
insgesamt 230 Feuerwehrleute kämpft man
mehreren Orten gegen die Ausbreitung der
Flammen
hitze-alarm auch in Italien das
Gesundheitsministerium hat für 20 Städte
die höchste Warnstufe ausgerufen in Rom
wurden mit über 41 Grad der bisherige
Hitze Rekord gebrochen heiße es ist nur
noch auf Sizilien in den Straßen von
Palermo schwitzen die Touristen aber
selbst den Hitze gewohnten Sizilianern
macht das Wetter zu schaffen
das größte Problem für uns ist die hohe
Luftfeuchtigkeit ansonsten sind wir
daran gewöhnt
eine drückende Hitze im Haus dass ich
vor die Tür gegangen bin um etwas Luft
zu schnappen
besonders für ältere Menschen kann die
Hitze lebensbedrohlich sein deshalb hat
die italienische Regierung nun einen
hitzeplan vorgestellt dieser regelt die
Behandlung von hitzepatienten in
Notaufnahmen und reaktiviert häusliche
Pflegedienste wer kann flüchtet in
diesen Tagen ans Meer doch mit 26 Grad
verspricht auch das nur wenig Abkühlung
und dabei hat die Hitzewelle am
Mittelmeer ihren Höhepunkt wohl noch
nicht erreicht
ganz andere Wetter extreme halten
Südkorea in Atem tagelange heftige
Regenfälle Überschwemmungen und
Erdrutsche in den betroffenen Regionen
in der Mitte und im Süden des Landes
suchen Rettungskräfte und das Militär
nach Vermissten mindestens 40 Menschen
sind ums Leben gekommen mehr als 10000
mussten ihre Häuser verlassen
jetzt nach Japan zu schwimmen WM Norbert
da ist das deutsche Team im goldraus ja
viel freiwasserwettbewerbe alle vier
geworden die deutsche Nationalhymne die
wird da gerade zum dauert am Wochenende
hatten Florian Wellbrock und Leonie Weg
bereits Gold über die 10 km geholt mit
dem Doppelsieg heute auch über die 5 KM
schreiben Sie WM Geschichte
Leonie Beck machte den Anfang nach Gold
über 10 km siegte die Würzburgerin als
erste deutsche Frau auch über die halbe
Distanz eine Energieleistung bei einer
Wassertemperatur von 28 Grad Florian
Wellbrock gelangt das gleiche Kunststück
früh übernahm der Magdeburger die
Führung im 5 km Rennen und brachte sie
souverän ins Ziel es ist auch sein
zweites Gold in Fukuoka ihre erste
Medaille konnten die deutschen
Wasserspringer bejubeln im
Teamwettbewerb er kämpften sich Timo
Bartel Christina Waffen Moritz Wesemann
und Lena Henschel die Bronze Medaille
ja und zweimal Gold gab es gestern Abend
auch für die deutschen Prothesen
Sprinterinnen und Sprinter zum Abschluss
der paralle Leichtathletik WM in Paris
nach dem Sieg von Irmgard Ben zusammen
über die 200 Meter holte Johannes den
Titel über die 400 Meter
sich fast selbst geschlagen Johannes
den eigenen Weltrekord nur um 300ste hol
zum dritten Mal nacheinander Gold über
400 Meter mit
45,81 Sekunden läuft bei allen davon und
am Ende nur noch gegen sich selbst die
letzte deutsche Medaille geht an
Weitsprung Weltmeister Leon Schäfer
Bronze über 100 Meter und das mit
persönlicher Bestzeit ein gelungener
Finaltag für das deutsche Team und viel
Motivation für die Paralympics im
kommenden Jahr
zur Tour de France nein erst noch diese
Meldung Weitsprung Weltmeisterin Malaika
mihambo wird nicht an der WM in Budapest
im August teilnehmen ihre Verletzung bei
den Deutschen Meisterschaften in Kassel
hat sich jetzt doch als Muskelfaserriss
erwiesen die Titelverteidigerin muss nun
passen aber jetzt zu Tode France der hat
heute Jonas singer seinen HD pokaccia
eine schwere Niederlage zugefügt der
Dede gewann das Einzelzeitfahren in
krummblumen mit großem Vorsprung und
verteidigte auf der 16 Etappe
eindrucksvoll die Gesamtführung will
überhaupt war eine Minute 38 schneller
als der zweitplatzierte und vergrößerte
den Abstand auf den Slowenen nun auf
eine Minute 48
ja und das ist vielleicht sogar eine
Vorentscheidung sind ja nur noch fünf
Etappen bis zum Ziel Paris am Sonntag
haben aber
als kräftige Gewitter in der Nacht mehr
dazu gleich von ostendali das heute
journal um viertel vor zehn mit
Christian Sievers wir wünschen Ihnen
noch einen schönen Abend bis morgen wenn
Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die Hitzewelle die
ja schon eine Weile andauert im
Mittelmeerraum die setzt sich weiter
fort und der hauptanzahl der Hitze wird
sich in den nächsten Tagen allmählich
ostwärts verschieben Richtung
Griechenland wir sehen aber die
Temperaturen liegen häufig über der 40
Grad Marke bei uns gibt es in der
kommende Nacht im südenschauer und
Gewitter im unwetterbereich mit Hagel
und Sturmböen ganz im Norden regnet es
ebenfalls dazwischen ist es aber
aufgelocker teils auch stärker bewölkt
weil tiefsten Temperaturen von 10 Grad
im Osten und 18 Grad z.B in Bayern ja
und morgen ziehen Schauer und einzelne
Gewitter ostwärts im Norden ganz im
Süden sind die Gewitter auch mal
kräftiger ansonsten im Westen da ist es
ja aufgelockert mit Sonnenschein mit
höchsten Temperaturen von 18 Grad in
Schleswig-Holstein und 30 Grad am
Oberrhein die nächsten Tage da setzen
sich die Schauer durchaus vor z.B am
Donnerstag hauptsächlich im Norden bei
18 bis 29 Grad am Freitag gibt es Blitz
und Donner und Samstag lockertes
teilweise wieder auf und damit ein
schöner Abend